good morning John our planet crashes
through on average around 50 tons of
stuff a day space is pretty empty but
earth is pretty big and it doesn't take
much to create a visible shooting star
the little Fleck of sky that you see
winking down at you is probably no
bigger than a grain of sand that's
almost everything we run into Little
Rock's that got flung off comets or
remnants from collisions of various
bodies in the solar system
a thing that's hard to remember about
the earth is that its rocky surface is
mostly very young geologically speaking
tectonic activity constantly eats up and
replaces the surface of the planet so
the average rock you might pick up
outside probably won't be much older
than 2 billion years old and there's a
really good chance it's younger than
dinosaurs but the little specks of dust
and metal that we run into every day
nearly all of them are older than the
oldest rock on earth that's not
precisely true though because there are
lots of rocks on earth that are not from
Earth they've recently fallen here and
the oldest particles on earth are
embedded in a meteorite and those
particles are over 7 billion years old
for context that's about two billion
years older than the Sun what percentage
of those bits of dust that we run into
every day are that old I don't know I
don't think anyone does we don't get to
learn about them because they get zapped
up by the atmosphere we just get to
watch them sometimes to find out about
space we have to go to it but in a form
of shooting stars it can come to us
indeed 0.2% of meteorites
those are meteoroids that actually land
on earth are from the Moon or Mars when
those bodies themselves get hit by big
meteorites it throws up a bunch of dust
and rocks that can eventually make their
way all the way here they're probably
also bits of Venus and Mercury that have
landed on earth but we've never found
one and yes some of the shooting stars
that we have run into are probably bits
of earth that were thrown up millions of
years ago by massive collisions in fact
Apollo 14 seems to have brought a rock
back from the moon that is actually from
Earth it might in fact be the oldest
earth rock since it was flung there more
than four billion years ago anyway I
just wanted to look at some shooting
stars today just the little ones the
regular ones not big fireballs or
meteorites not the newsworthy ones just
tiny bits of ancient dust from comets or
asteroids or planets zipping into the
thin but dense blanket of our atmosphere
hitting it so hard and fast that they
heat up until they and the gases around
them visibly glow and they're billions
of years of existence becomes just
another little beauty for us to be
grateful for
John my author copies RN physical copy
with the actual words that are gonna be
in the book in the book oh really nice
together as well you can see that this
one is a little longer that's not by
design there was just a lot of story to
tell it also just got its first review
from the Library Journal they say not
this adventurous witty and compelling
novel Greene delivers sharp social
commentary on the power of social media
and both the benefits and horrendous
consequences that follow when we give
too much of ourselves to technology it's
fair I'm super excited and also pretty
nervous
hence the watching shooting stars video
thank you by the way to Thomas Lindemann
who let me use all of his footage that
he takes of shooting stars link to his
channel in the description where there
will also be information about the
digital book tour we're doing and how to
pre-order the book John I'll see you on
Tuesday